on the Nobel Prize talks podcast I
always stress the scientists a matter of
not knowing things and wanting to their
things rather than know anything Tim
hunt if you'll talk about
knowledge-based economy but I think
science is our ignorance based that's
the whole point in conversation with me
Adam Smith I mean knowing what you don't
know is where the where the growth
points yes come from of course you have
to know what you don't know and what you
could know that that's the difficult bin
because every anybody any fool can say
well I'd like now how the brain works
but there's not much hope have a listen
to the podcast on nobelprize.org iTunes
and on Android devices